do you think eating an avocado is worth
losing a hand yes yeah I'm Spencer I'm
Michelle and today we're gonna be
testing out avocado gadgets I love
avocados growing up in California you
must have to love avocados I feel like I
didn't know what an avocado was until
like five years ago
there are times and you just come so
close to like glancing off of the pic
the other day I had a really soft
avocado and I went to do that with the
Pitons a nice like barely missed my
finger so that was a sobering moment but
yeah apparently there's something called
avocado hand where people are cutting
their hands so much trying to cut open
or pit avocados that hospitals have
given them the name I was trying to open
up an avocado and I stabbed myself we're
gonna test out some gadgets that are
gonna help us crack open these delicious
avocados and eat them hopefully without
cutting our hands open
oh it's shaped like a little avocado
that's cute there's like a circle here
with like four blades
oh wait the bottom comes out oh so then
you can just have a lava cod of slices
without having to slice individual ones
but also yeah you grab the pit with this
and at the bottom edge of that avocado
slice thing use it to open it also cut
it oh okay you want some guac got it
yeah I'm into how multi-purpose this is
[Music]
q2 is slow motion let's go you Randy
yeah let's try these babies oh it's kind
of sharp is that how you cut open an
avocado yeah I got cut in half first
rate cut it like that it's go like this
I didn't hurt myself
it almost slips look at that now we have
to get out the pit using this leg a
little doodad I feel you right you push
it down but mine's not grabbing it's
just like you push it down twist I feel
like oh and then of this then then you
can just like yeah let's try slicing all
right oh wait it won't go down I have to
like kind of push it through
yeah little slices yeah so I've
obviously you're like bashing yours up
I'm just making guac you know look how
beautiful that is and that's all right
let's start mashing this baby oh it's
like play-doh it is it's kind of gross
the way that it like see it like
squishes up mashed up to perfection if I
was making guac this is like really easy
okay I will say I am happy with how all
these gadgets are working out however
this is a lot more to like wash than a
knife yes or fork I would almost want to
rather get an avocado hand because I
would just rather use a knife and a fork
she wants to get hurt so that's I'm just
saying like look at how messy this thing
is alright we're ready for the next
gadget oh this looks kind of funky this
looks like a hand
but is it but it also makes me feel like
this is just so easy to like like slap
someone with it no this is like a
slapping game and no I just wanna sit
across on someone
Wow it looks like a hand obviously this
is for the pit but how do you slice with
this this is a cutter open really yeah
and then this will be - you know do the
slices alright let's do this
dang it went through like butter you
know what I do want to say that I like
the fact that this gadget is just like
one piece like the other one had so many
like different items and this one is
just easy to use and fast yeah
alright you want to try to put it now
yeah oh oh okay my picked it up and
everything Oh your pits my pay is too
small
oh just get out I'm so proud of my
little avocado great job
oh dang it's got a good hold all right
ready let's slice this baby I mean these
gadgets were made for Spencer I am
struggling I think I made walking on it
is a terrible mess neither of these
gadgets I hate them both I want my knife
I want my fork I'll have an avocado
handgun anyway mine turned out just fine
meanwhile still struggling I don't know
what happened here obviously a disaster
you know what we'll move on I like this
one this one looks like a little wing
it's a door or mall feel like I've seen
this one before
again it's got your knife it's got your
pitter-patter your putter and it's got
your slicer slicer real yeah let's do it
slicing with these is just like a dream
come true like oh wait yours is perfect
yes and I think the pits gonna fit this
time I do like that this one would get
smaller so yes so you can actually do it
no matter what pit size it is oh is it
my first perfect avocado I think so this
got just a winner
I was not so perfect this far but it's
fine let's slice this baby up it's just
so satisfying
I get it right finally kind of oh my god
is this the one for me slice please no
look almost perfect here let me help you
perfect done yes perfect beautiful the
best what's that they weren't so
hopefully these gadgets will keep us
safe from avocado hand I think this one
the slicer was super easy the pitter
actually can grab onto any size the
slicer on this one I felt like for
whatever reason it seemed to fit the
avocado better that's Michelle's most
user-friendly gadget this is my favorite
one because first it looks like a hand a
second you know I like how you can hold
it like this and then cut as opposed to
being like and I don't know I just think
that this is the most like useful one I
do understand what you mean by like not
fitting all the pits I don't know I like
this one the best
I mean I'll probably still use a knife
just cuz I'm it's habit but I I do like
the gadgets so you know use one of these
avoid a knife and stay safe out there
avocado lovers
[Music]